I grew up as a child
zhuzi and passionate about doing things
that were adventurous getting out and
exploring the planet and whether it was
motorcycles or boats or airplanes flying
was something that one of the very early
aids I found very inspirational
it was the ultimate of freedom
[Music]
Aviation today is really about moving
your body from A to B but when it comes
to enjoying flying as an experience it
doesn't exist it's not about eight years
in the Air Force flying f-16s what I
left the military and came back to
Stanford Business School I was trying to
get out of a flight suit into a business
suit I happened to notice one day in a
magazine a little obscure rule change
and it was the FAA saying that they were
going to announce a new class of
airplane called light sport airplanes a
new class of license called the support
pilot and the concept was to finally
make airplanes accessible to the average
human being make them safe and
affordable and a license that you could
get in a matter of a couple of weeks so
that was a Momo I what aviation could be
and as an academic exercise I'm just
going to study it in each class I would
spend them towards something related
this project so the first one was a
market analysis and AHA was whoa that
there's a big market here bigger than I
expected the other aha moment was if a
start-up does not do this it likely will
not materialize I had a business plan
and I had thrown the switch to on
Kirk and I met in a design class an
engineering design class at Stanford and
every project we had Kirk found a way to
turn that project into some kind of
aviation experience we actually
reconnected later on when I was teaching
practice I in Stanford and he was back
at the GSB and we reconnected over over
lunch during lunch it hit me
can I show you PowerPoint and he goes
all right so I pull up my powerpoint he
basically detailed out all of the
opportunity and I go yeah I think you're
the guy I'm looking for what you know
about the consumer product design
process what your teaching is Tamara
what you lived and breathed the airplane
world doesn't know I know enough about
that to know I need somebody like you
it's easy for me okay I can see where
this could be in the future and that's
why as the story goes in the next
morning I'm calling them up thing goes I
so get this because I'm in I'm all in
what do you need in a way you could say
that the work that Kirk did it the GSB
is directly leading to this product we
have that's the beginning of the DNA of
the company if you want to take
advantage of this recreational
opportunity the best way to do that is
to bring recreational flood to the
forefront and really make a power sport
out of aviation when it's time I left
Stanford I felt confident enough for my
fundamental business acumen
understanding of things that I could
walk in any boardroom with any business
executive and I felt comfortable having
a dialogue and that confidence is
important and the tool set that I got
there was invaluable in the next phase
and that is creating the company as we
move from business strategy into
implementation and design what should
this airplane be what should it deliver
what's the lifestyle how will people use
it we quickly honed in on this know
right we'll have an amphibious airplane
allows you to fly and land on land or
land on water it's not airport to
airport
this is Airport to off airport so we
have folding wings that allows you
transportation to move your airplane
wherever you want to take it makes it
more recreational now you take a camping
fishing exploring whatever you want and
so it company's more than an airplane
it's about really honoring the human
experience and delivering something that
when you finally go out and fly you find
out you can fly it's safe you can learn
to do it a reason about of time you
actually can't afford it our goal is for
our customers when they come back the
first time and they fly this thing they
go oh my god but all those things tie
back to that original strategy that came
out of the GSB which is we are going to
create a power sport around recreational
flying it's a two person one engine
relatively lightweight simple airplane
that a new sport pilot can learn the fly
in about two weeks very safely and you
look at the airplane you look at the
cockpit and you go it's routes will be
simple I can understand this cockpit
looks like something I can do that
doesn't happen by accident it happens by
people who understand that process the
design process that Ikon is really based
on what we learned at Stanford and
that's the classic id8 build test and
repeat and you learn from that testing
and then you go back and you iterate
that process again we the first
conventional aircraft has met the full
FAA spin resistance standard so what
that means for you is it's very safe
[Music]
what the a5 is is an unadulterated
unapologetic representation and
execution of what flying is romantically
designed to be and that's this human
aspirational experience I think both
Kirk and I feel like Stanford has been
transformative in our personal lives and
our careers I can say this emphatically
if it was not for my experiences at
Stanford both in the engineering school
in design school and the business school
Icahn would not exist all of the sort of
Stanford networks and connections and
influencers that we still rely on today
it's easy to say that without those
Stanford experiences Icahn would not
have been an idea and it certainly
wouldn't have reached the place where it
is today feel indebted because that that
experience but was critical to where we
have come from the day and where we're
going in the future
[Music]